[Music]
let's talk about your show your show is
hilarious you have said an interview
that you could never have a desk if you
were hosting a show and although I
admire what you have going on here I
love this it feels right just keep
rubbing that - yeah yeah I have to say
we started in 1993 and never like it was
just so long ago right I remember
thinking I've grew up wanting to host a
show like this is a little kid and I
would sit behind a desk and pretend to
be Johnny Carson be like wow I'm at my
desk and I got my microphone a little
thing yeah and so I've always been very
comfortable with it but you would say no
you don't I knew when we were putting
the show together I knew that we
couldn't have a desk because you know
kind of there's a lot of desks and it
didn't feel right for us to have that
but also I knew that if I gave myself
something to retreat behind I would
either just hide behind it or all the
energy that I put into the show would
just end up in my face and then I would
just make crazy lunatic faces the entire
time and wave my hands
[Applause]
yeah
[Applause]
and yeah snacks under there I have
snacks I'm urinating right now I have
this whole thing set up for my comfort
here I don't get a desk and there's no
reason that this should be seen on TV
between the two of us the one that needs
something hiding this is me not again
why don't we get you it'd be great if
you had a desk there I'll get you a desk
all right gonna get you a desk I love it
if you have it Vaseline to date if you
had a desk would be great if he had a
desk and a microphone and and it looked
exactly like mine and they just flank
right at the V and you set right there
and feel very much like you are at an
H&R block deciding between who is gonna
be attacks I would love it if you had
like a crazy snack back there like just
like a bowl of peanuts this big or
something
no there's nothing back well if you're
Ellie there's some Orbitz sugarless gum
that I think the crew eats I don't need
let's get a free ad for orbit
or bit it's what I view how you do it
yes Annie wet ones
okay Oh place for the animal yeah yeah
no the animal acts and some guess yeah
you